nature is quantum mechanical each
particle doesn't have a definite
position and instead exists in a cloud
of probabilities until it is measured
this is why computers are not very good
at accurately simulating nature because
each time you add just one more particle
to a system you're adding a near
Infinity of places it could be and it
becomes exponentially harder to compute
Richard Fineman said that we must let
the computer itself be built of quantum
mechanical elements a quantum computer
could more accurately simulate nature
because every time a new particle is
added to a system the quantum computer
could store the state of that particle
in a cubit a cubit is the Quantum
version of a bit which is normally just
zero or one a cubit can exist in a
superp position a combination of zero
and one until it is measured one company
working on this right now is Q control
which has an online learning platform
called Black Opal where you can explore
more of these ideas